Disney
Jerry Bruckheimer
[Song Plays]
The dead have taken command of the sea
They're searching for a girl
and Pearl and the Sparrow
DEAD MEN TELL NO TALES!
Pirates had infected the seas for generations
So I vowed to eliminate them all
Jack Sparrow
Cursed Me
I will have my REVENGE!
Are you sure that you are THE Jack Sparrow?
Where is your pants?
A Great Pirate does not require such intricacies
Find Sparrow
Karena is the only one who can help us
I am not looking for trouble
What a horrible way to live
[Jack Screams]
I am a women of science
I choose not to believe in ghosts
Don't you see that what is behind us?
Monkey
Are all pirates this stupid?
[Crew] Yes Yeah
This film contains scenes that may be too intense for younger viewers